hey everyone what is going on today is
going to be a little bit of a fun video
we are going to take the all new sony
xperia pro i their new smartphone one
inch sensor the touting all these great
specs in it right we're going to put it
against the all new sony a74 now i got
them both in here for review
a74 here
xperia pro i here right right okay so we
all know that this the a74 will probably
be the best camera you know we got a
full frame sensor 30 plus megapixels in
this you've got the all the new
algorithm with the autofocusing all that
comes into play right right
but what does the xperia pro i give us
gives us pro cinema modes gives us pro
video modes gives us pro photography
modes eye tracking uh face track all
that kind of stuff comes into play with
this so you're getting a lot of that
technology that we're getting into the
sony alpha cameras is coming into the
xperia pro i but anyway we're going to
be doing is meeting zacky over at the
national arts gallery here in singapore
we're going to walk around shoot some
night shots see how these perform in low
light
lightroom welcome back to you with my
final thoughts
[Music]
all right guys we're at the light
tonight festival is that right light
tonight that's it at the national
gallery it's like an art festival week
here in singapore so we're actually
gonna be taking some photos here we're
gonna go around take some night shots
some little light shots of course with
the a7 4 and the xperia pro iii for
imaging
because this is packed with a one inch
sensor
but we know the lens doesn't cover the
entire sensor we'll get all that details
in just a bit but anyway we're gonna do
some little light photography
some video see how these two perform
and you get to decide for yourself which
one would you want to own
okay so first here i am going to take a
photo of this little installation now on
the a74 i have a g master 35 1.4 lens
now because syria pro i don't have a 1.4
aperture only it does maximum two i'm
gonna set this to two so we're probably
not even playing fields let's see how
this goes i'm too close all i get is the
knight the lightning that's all i see
let's get the stair here
not too bad with this 30 plus megapixel
sensor now we're going to go into the
xperia pro i
one of the cool things about this system
of course is you're getting a lot of the
sony tech that you're seeing the a74 the
alpha one the a92 it's all coming into
this
and then you also have your different
modes here so if i want to go into just
like you would get on a sony camera your
shutter your manual
program auto auto
then go to basic if you just want basic
mode let the camera do everything for
you you don't have to think anyway zach
where we going next you're gonna go
what's that artsy stuff that's art okay
here we go
all right
you ready wow what's that man
do we got music on this too
that's pretty cool man
[Music]
going right into this
okay so now we're doing a vlogging test
here to see how this looks and sounds
with
this one inch sensor
now i'm using not the cinema mode but
the pro mode there's two versions of the
video modes here on the xperia pro i the
cinema version we'll try that in just a
bit
but obviously you don't vlog in with
cinema phones but
this modus was supposed to emulate let's
say the a7s3 the a74 more of those pro
sumo sony cameras but we can see how the
uh audio is the dynamic range there's
exactly right behind me
how it focuses
let's see that does it focus on yuzaki
back to me should have eye tracking
let's see how this rolls
okay so now we're trying with the cinema
mode here 4k 69
aspect ratio been a cs profile on this
you can't shoot flat you can't do like s
log one two or three not in the phone
yet maybe in an update but uh i know for
trying this out so it won't look as
punchy or as vibrant
as what we saw on the pro video side of
things but unless it's more for the
cinema
cinema so yeah that's you know what the
funny thing is when i'm doing the
comparison like this
the evf makes everything look washed out
and
the phone screen looks so good
again i know that's obviously
you know that's not
representative of the actual photo i am
shooting and raw on this versus of
course you know ron jpeg but still
it's uh
it's a little disheartening when you
look through the evf of this thing
one thing about this phone we're at a
bus stop right now so it's loud right
there's so many buttons on this phone
that activate things from the dedicated
camera button the custom button the
power button
that it's very easy for this one to
activate in your pocket
so i've taken this out of my pocket a
few times already and the camera is
already on
which shouldn't be the case because
it's activated a few times hopefully
no sensitive information went out or did
it so now we're going to do a camera
test with this neon light behind us now
this massive capital theater this is
pretty iconic here for a lot of us
photographers in singapore let's see how
both of these cameras perform with it
any blowout how much detail can they
hold
let's find out
all right zacky hey seven four
a couple things that are very difficult
to use on this phone is that there's no
on screen button to take a photo you
have to use
the manual of the button on the side of
the phone which makes it very cumbersome
at times especially you saw him doing
portrait mode and i want to do landscape
landscape it's fine portrait mode i want
to press here
but there's nothing that i can see on
the screen that allows me to do that so
this is very awkward right here i gotta
hold it like this
to take the photo
portrait mode
now when i go to basic mode i get that
button back okay
the problem is
i lose all that customization
that i had so it would have been nice if
sony would allow us to have
you know that on-screen button even in
pro mode
because
this phone is long and slender it's not
the easiest thing to hold in portrait
mode anyway small thing okay you're
gonna do a lightsaber i'm gonna take
photos of zacky
closer to you bring the one closer to
you closer make it a lightsaber oh there
we go i can see zacky now
now with xperia pro i go iso
here we go let me try 50 millimeters
because there's no depth of field on
this
tough
interesting
very interesting the phone's eye
tracking
works better than the a74 who would have
thought that
it got your face the a74 got your face
jackie but
the phone was able to recognize the eye
right away now in terms of depth of
field no competition are you gonna see
the colors out of the phone are not bad
i'm pretty impressed with it now this is
just by looking at this 4k oled display
what we'll do now i'm thinking zac is
we'll go back i'll put these on the
computer i'll edit some of the better
photos out
then i'll show you guys the comparisons
between the xperia pro y and the a74
i'll come back to with my final thoughts
this video is brought to you by secret
lab here at geek culture we love our
secret lab chairs especially the all new
2022 titan evo with its revamped 4-way
lumbar system for enhanced back support
if p leather 2.0 isn't your cup of tea
then consider the all-new soft weave
even more soft and breathable than
before the chair comes in more colors
including this lovely frost blue the
titan evo is even magnetized allowing
the head pillow to stick on the headrest
without straps of course there are even
more new features so do check them out
at secretlab.co
alright guys we are back in lightroom
now taking a look at images here from
the a74 and of course the xperia pro i
now as we know look a cell phone
smartphone however you want to call it
camera is not going to best
a full-frame camera system it's just not
but of course it's about ease of use
it's the camera that's in your pocket
that's the most important and are able
to capture the images that you want the
details the clarity et cetera et cetera
now when we use smartphone cameras we
shoot in bright daylight everything
looks great everything is sharp because
low iso performance everything comes
into play
but when we go into lower light
situations
how do these images stack up against a
full frame camera sensor
i mean we know who's going to win but
just how are they going to stack up so
let's do a little bit of a comparison
with you real quick on that then i'll
show you some images from the a7 as well
to show you the low light performance
okay
let's go to this one here real quick
this is from the a74 here you can see
that
and iso 435 millimeters f2 because i was
shot at f2 majority of the time because
that's the fastest aperture that's on
the xperia pro i it doesn't go down to
1.4 or anything else like that so i
stuck it at f2 and as you can see right
here the image is really really sharp uh
tack sharp and as you can see noise is
pretty well controlled i mean obviously
400 iso so it's going to be relatively
good
now let's go to the xperia pro i
all right
things didn't pair out so well did they
okay iso 800 f 2.4 one over 50th of a
second
now
this was on auto mode for the most part
so it decided to capture it at this
point but as you can see right here the
noise even at 800 is really really bad
now i could throw this into opacity
noise and i could clean up a little bit
but it just goes to show you
uh it is a significant difference plus
you don't see the depth of field as much
as you would on the uh
a74 again full frame larger lens etc etc
but if you were to put this on social
media clean it up a little bit put a
little noise reduction on there it would
pass no issues at all as a matter of
fact i'm zooming in but if i hold it
back here it looks good and that's how
people are really seeing your images on
social media so i'll give this one a
pass okay to be fair here
it's not all uh you know rose is here
with the a74 sensor that we're shooting
this image here
kind of seeing a lot of noise creeping
in here and i don't know why we're out
we're iso 1600 and this is pretty
significant here and i'm shooting at 35
millimeters at f2 one over one
hundredths of a second
and uh that's a lot of noise again you
can clean that up in topaz de noise but
still
a little bit more than i was expecting
on that especially iso 1600 let's kind
of zoom in again a little bit here you
do lose a little bit of detail i brought
that back through my edit a bit but
still
uh
yeah could be better but you know for
the most part not too bad right here's
one last uh test i'm going to show you
the difference between the two here's
the a74 here
and this was iso 125 35 millimeters f2
now this is going to be iso 125 it's
going to be tac sharp right trying to
capture the lights these neon lights
these led lights in here to give a sense
of how it captures the tonality of that
now this has been edited slightly
let me show you the before edit
after edit before edit after edit okay
let's go to
the xperia
iso 160.
um this is at
six
millimeters f2 okay
again smartphone so we're gonna do on
that um i did crop that in just a tad
bit because it was quite a large kind of
went on a wide on that but nonetheless
let's take a look
i gotta say not too bad at all you're
not gonna get the same tonality on these
kind of small sensors especially when it
comes to these bright lights as harsh
contrast of lights but this does handle
it relatively well again and there's
pretty there's some good play in these
files here look at the details i'm able
to pull out through the highlights and
the shadows this is not bad this is not
bad at all for a smartphone i mean is it
the best i'm seeing out of any
smartphone out there no but this is good
comparing it between these two so there
you have it i mean very very impressive
all right guys so those are my uh
thoughts between the two images here
we'll show you some video samples and it
will go to my final thoughts
[Music]
all right so as you saw in lightroom
obviously the sony a74 is the better
camera out of the two but let's talk
about the xperia pro i for a moment here
now i really liked this smartphone on
paper even in person it's really well
built beautiful the 4k display is
awesome it's got the snapdragon 888 it
is stacked with all the latest specs
however
you're not utilizing that full one-inch
sensor why because the lens isn't big
enough to cover the entire sensor so
you're basically about the same as other
smartphones out there there are some
caveats to this first off it's the image
quality as we saw a little light doesn't
really hold up when we go to pro cinema
mode we're using the venice cs profile
and all that kind of stuff it just
really falls apart it doesn't look good
in low light everything looks mushy it
looks blurry it's not sharp and you
don't get to utilize all that great auto
focusing um algorithms that sony put
into their you know alpha line which you
get in the pro video mode and this is
where i think sony's got a little bit
confusing with the phone here they have
essentially made this
a pocketable camera that also is a phone
in my personal opinion but
you have to choose three different apps
to do various different things
why not put it all in one app sony make
it a lot easier you know a tab tab for
pro you know tab for cinema if you want
to go to photography you boom you're
right into there also there's no
on-screen button if you want to take uh
any sort of shots with that within the
photography mode or even in video you
have to use the on camera button the
camera but on the body which is a little
bit
perplexing at times now yes you can go
into your basic mode and utilize that in
the photo mode
but
why not have that button there because
if we want to shoot portrait mode as i
was trying to do sometimes or want to do
landscape i have that option using this
on-screen button versus the physical
button because it can be a little bit
cumbersome anyway uh overall though i
think sony's on the right track with the
xperia pro i but i don't think it's
quite there yet i would say if you want
to make a pro
smartphone camera system
we don't care if there's a large hump on
the back of it we would rather have a
full-size lens to cover that sensor
versus a small lens that doesn't utilize
that one-inch sensor to its maximum
capabilities now let's talk about the
a74 now a lot of people love this camera
and i do too i think it's going to be
this is going to be the main seller and
the alpha series for a lot of people out
there this is the camera they're going
to go to now i do love that they have
increased the megapixels on this i do
love they have the new menu system the
flip out rotatable display basically it
is an a7 s3 body but now where you have
an a74 system in it now you do have that
customizable dial which i really do
enjoy which is nice so you can customize
this to your liking i like this and
hopefully they will add this into other
cameras in the future sometimes they
test some of these things on low end
cameras to see how it performs and how
people take to it and then they
obviously they add it in the future to
the higher end camera systems but i
think the a74 is a really nice
photographer's camera it's a really nice
videographer's camera you're not gonna
get that 4k 120 but to be honest with
you do you really need 4k 120 if you're
doing a lot of your content on instagram
or facebook or youtube for that matter
does it make a difference
i mean there's an argument to be had yes
or no right it's always great to have
more resolution so you can punch in if
you need to
but i think if you are a seasoned
videographer or someone that knows your
camera systems knows how to maximize
what is inside the camera you're going
to be able to
do some wonderful things with the a74
also the new color profiles to this the
new auto focusing algorithm you are
really lined up for having a fantastic
camera that's going to be
i mean it's going to last you for a good
few years like the a7 3 before for a lot
of you out there i would say the a74 it
is a fantastic all-around camera and
you're going to get some great images as
you saw here in lightroom and as you've
seen in this video so anyway those are
my thoughts on the two let me know your
thoughts in the comments section below
what did you think of the xperia pro y
what did you think of the a74 any
questions you have of course ask me i
will try to answer them for you with
that guys subscribe to the channel if
you can follow us on facebook stay safe
out there and i'll chat to you soon take
care
[Music]
you